okay first of all there's a very
important checkpoint called a start for
the east this checkpoint is to for the
cell to decide should I go through the
process of division or not this is very
important why because I have to make the
decision to make sure I have enough
resources to replicate my genome to
divide you know we all owe over
ourselves from one the fertilized egg
had picks themselves right I'm going to
divide and divide and divide the
committee to different self fate so each
cell type is actually fate and that's
also a decision when you become a skin
cell when you come a neuron cell and all
the cells have one genome but different
fates
actually each cell fate it's like a
bunch of genes they win your muscle and
then your own heart and stem cell is
like nobody yet a dominating we can use
mathematics to understand how and why a
stem cell chip can become another cell
faith and another cell faith can become
a stem stem cell but I believe there
will be new math for example numismatics
simply by studying the life phenomena
[Music]
yeah yeah so like cellular
decision-making will make it will be new
math that we incur example or how we
think how the brain how the brain
function and how do we describe life
what's the mathematical language what's
the logic
[Music]
Nihao everybody welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on we are on
site in the beautiful Beijing China at
Peking University we are now going to be
talking about quantitative biology we
have dr. Xiao Chun joining us on the
show hi Joe nice meeting you thank you
so much for coming on our program really
appreciate it thank you for inviting me
you're super welcome and such a
fascinating person check out this bio
everyone for those that don't know dr.
Chow hyung is the co-discoverer of
self-organized criticality and the
sample model which are revolutionary
breakthroughs in understanding how
complexity arises in nature he's
currently chair professor of physics and
systems biology at picking University
founding director of the
interdisciplinary Center for
quantitative biology at Peking
University founding co-editor in chief
of the journal quantitative biology
fellow of the American Physical Society
as well as principal investigator of the
tongue lab which has 20 to 30
undergraduate and graduate students
studying quantitative biological systems
and you can find the links in the bio
below to the tong lab as well as the
center for quantitative biology and the
Wikipedia page Rho let's start things
off with one of our favorite questions
that we like asking our guests what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world I am optimistic I think science
and technology will take us very far I
think that that's the main driving force
for world many things will change
including maybe the definition of what
is life and our ethics etc but I'm
excited I think the world will evolve to
a more and more wonderful place for us
to explore and to enjoy yes what would
you say is a key principle that we can
embody and pass on to the next
generations that will help ensure that
we have a prosperous
world first of all we have to be
peaceful the most important the world is
really one world we have just one
village I hope everybody realizes that
so we can work together to have a global
view to have everyone educated to live
the power poverty and then go from there
yeah
peace peace unity no poverty and patient
education yeah
and disease and all this they will I
think there will be eventually will be
solved all these problems yeah and I
especially love interviewing leaders
that have been pushing the edge of
Science and Technology forward for such
a long time because the advancements
that are found at the edge of science
and technology at the edge of
civilizations and knowledge about fields
are typically what ends up eradicating
poverty increasing education increasing
health eradicating disease these are the
big things that enable people to live
healthier more creative lives and peace
and unity is again just one globe that
we have to share that everyone has lived
on the forests that built this beautiful
world did you know that the number of
people that lived and died before us is
approximated to be about 100 billion
people hmm
no I didn't know that I just I love that
statistic it's one where I always try
and like get behind the eyes of the
different people that helped build
society over the big time it depends on
way of define when we in the stock of
the people yeah I think I believe this
and it's are like six million years ago
or so and
and it's always also interesting seeing
if you can you know power loss very well
and if you apply Perret oh the power law
here you can hypothesize that maybe just
twenty billion of the people made 80
percent of civilizations advancements
and that's always interesting well who
are those people and how did they think
and what did they build I love asking
stuff like that
let's talk about your journey so born in
the jungle sheet
Jhansi province that's men okay and who
were you as a kid and how did you get
interested in science okay so my
childhood was kind of interesting I grew
up during the Cultural Revolution so
essentially starting from the second or
third grade elementary school the the
cultural routine started and then
there's no formal education for many
years so we just play and find whatever
interesting books we can read well there
weren't much books you can find at that
time so there are few books left on on
the shelves of my home science books
that's uh if I translated into English
is like ten thousand wise and and and
the one of the books I is uh it's about
physics questions I think that's one of
the main reasons I got into it I got
interested in new physics plus I had
excellent physics teacher in middle
school yeah what okay this book is great
yeah to 10,000 wise a lot of stuff like
that and many volumes for this book but
the other few volumes left on the Shelf
one is the physics module yeah the
physics volume of the 10000 physics wise
and because questions is ours our way to
probe rial
and ask great questions and gives you a
better quality of life and not being shy
and just asking the great questions are
so important okay
what about for those that don't know I
don't know what was this like what do
you mean by like during the Cultural
Revolution what happened with school
like there was no teachers without
during a long period of time maybe a
year or two the school simply was shut
down and no classes and then the class
resumed but the the stuff we learned are
very sort of very elementary and simple
stuff there's no serious class and for
example there's only very simple
mathematics and physics you don't learn
anything like history biology literature
geography philosophy so the very very
narrow education with very thin piece of
knowledge but a couple years later when
you're in middle school you already had
a great physics teacher so I had come
back yeah well yeah well I had a great
physics teacher but the stuff he was
teaching in the classroom wasn't that
complicated either but that's enough he
he inspired me here so I got interested
in physics so in some sense maybe it
doesn't matter how much how many books
do you read during your childhood is
something you got excited and you and
you feel passionate yes and that's an
important step in empathy for so many
people what would it be like if we just
had like a two year just like absence of
school systems in general and it shows
in so many ways like just the fragility
of what can happen in a child's life and
in a cultures progress and I think
that's very important to try and like
get behind it like what would it be like
good thing you found the ten thousand
physics wise and and this type of stuff
okay but then how about the pursuing of
physics and you went to university and
mechanics and this was at the you STC
university of science and technology of
china correct
okay so Turkish down this path yeah the
after after high school at that time we
we were still during the in a period of
cultural revolution so there was no
normal channel to go to college but then
two years later the the things are being
studied his great reform and the one of
the things he started is to open the
college to to the to normal people to
this huge number of young people by I
took through it a thorough examination
it was it the GAO how back then check
out that's the first Gaucho it was a
first half-year evolution what year was
that first cow cover that's 77 77 that's
right and prior to that what was the
University for just how could how did
people get into university before well
well if before Cultural Revolution
there was cow cow it just stopped for
ten years during culture okay yeah and
and a half the cow cow was reinstalled I
took out how and when to call I went to
the University of Science and Technology
of China I wanted to stay physically our
university us TC which was I hope it
still is was the the best university in
China the hardest university for young
for young people they don't take physics
students in our province because they
think our part means maybe the
educational level is not so high so they
only have quota for students in the
mechanics department so I went to the
department of modern mechanics but
nonetheless I like physics so I studied
the physics I went to physics class and
made physics friends
so I kept my interesting physics yeah
yeah mechanics and physics have so much
in common
that's in common overlap so then and
this is a whole separate conversation to
be so interesting to have someone on the
show that knows ding shoppings a
cultural reform because there's so much
nuance to it that I would love to
eventually be able to interview someone
on that exact subject but this reopening
of the universities was so important and
then you actually went on this cool
program it's caspia that's right so
during my third year in college I think
and then we suddenly had this program we
heard about it I said the at that time
there was no normal channel for Chinese
students to go to the u.s. to study
there was no gie no TOEFL exams and the
US universities they don't know how to
meet Chinese students there's no formal
channel but the the the Nobel laureate
professor titi Lee he saw this and he
won't he wanted to start program by
himself okay so he initiated program
it's called china-us physics examination
and application 1980 so he contacted by
his new friends is a great physicist he
contact us our physics departments of
around 50 universities and get organized
and then to to administrate exams in
China and then to select Chinese
students to go to the US okay so I I was
lucky again in the first first year for
this program to start a cold wave I took
the exam and ended up in the University
of Chicago Physics Department to study
physics to start my PhD study
Wow that program you were telling me
before we started that it went on 10
years and then it stopped and I love
stuff like this if we can inspire more
programs like that around the world that
do these great cultural and knowledge
exchanges across the planet we have a
much greater propensity for that peace
and that harmony that we were talking
about the beginning so ok so this
program brought you to the University of
Chicago where you did your PhD in
physics and tell us about the first like
immersion into the United States what
was that feeling like the culture the
people the science the university what
was that like well well I would say it
says a big cultural shock right from
every aspects the way professors taught
classes I had an American roommate we
get along fine but then we had also some
now frictions it's very different from
from China
how roommates get along with each other
but in the end we both understood each
other and all one thing shocked me that
I the first day I went to the physics
department now I got five or seven keys
so like I have lots of keys every door I
need a key right so that's new yeah many
of these small cultural shocks yeah but
I enjoyed it
really I I I lived in the International
House you know the Chicago's
International house built by Rockefeller
I believe and his initial Rock
University kaga was sponsored by
Rockefeller initially I think he said
initial belief is to peer this
international house is to have people
together from different cultures
and that really served me a lot so I
spent first two quarters half a year in
the International House
although the rent was very high I
basically owe my salary yet by twenty a
I was pay rent and food and that's it
yeah but I made many friends from
different countries and different
culture including many Taiwanese and
Hong Kong his friends so that was a
great experience
yeah very similar with my first
immersion into China huh I felt a very
beautiful spirit that took me in and the
warmly and the people and culture has
just been the art and the has just been
so fun to be immersed and then I almost
feel like you're I get to live through
your first experience other people can
hopefully live through my first
experience oh hopefully we can catalyze
more of these first experiences around
the world but how did you under picking
what in physics you wanted to do it's
such a broad field there's so many
different ways to tackle it how did you
pick what you wanted to do I I somehow
got into statistical physics late in my
college time I think one of the reason
is that at that time the yeah they say
there was no barrel a price given to
Prigogine to award him in in statistical
physics in angry Korean systems so maybe
that had impacted me but also maybe of
my interest to sort of daily life
problems like why skies blue by way of
clouds why waves in the ocean or white
so others are the problems very close
related nature and then a statistical
physics is a tool
to deal with all these matters of phases
of matter how many different parts
particles molecules put them together
how would they behave in general
collectively together like if like we
have many individual individuals we have
all our own personality but when we are
together we can do something together
very differently so in physics very
similar well if you have individual
ingredients they look very normal
nothing fancy but if you put many of
them together the summing phenomena
emerge so we call this emergent
phenomena like super conductivity phase
transitions like water become gas become
ice they suddenly makes something change
drastically yeah
laser many many examples the analogy to
humans is very important here because
it's one that's super relatable for for
us that we as an individual have our own
personality behaviors but then when you
add a second person is a person your mom
or your dad someone very close to you as
a person
maybe someone you've never met before
how does that change the dynamic what
about when you're in a group of a
hundred or a thousand exactly yeah the
best example celebrate well you know if
you just pick a single neurone it's not
so fancy right you just some spikes if
some electricity some spikes you put
them together and you get conscious you
get partisan is to get everything we
still don't that instead well that's a
best example of emergent phenomena yeah
more it's different yeah yeah the in
that quote goes the whole is greater
than the sum of its parts
absolutely and that's emergent phenomena
that's worse
and this is interesting that the
phenomena is evident at like you were
describing this molecular or neuronal
cellular level and it's also evident at
a civilizational web smoothly society
level mm-hmm yeah the society is the
collective behaviors emerge in the
phenomena now the many individuals start
together then we have the society with
this hierarchies of society active
countries we have economies and
governments corporations Fe and we have
monetary system yeah we have stocks
stock market something completely
imaginary is yeah this the the
phenomenon of the civilization has been
incredibly interesting creations that
emerge from it that if we were just the
eight billion nodes separate wouldn't
necessarily emerge it's so interesting
ok so I see how the worldview starts
building out so now Brookhaven National
Lab this is where the postdoc happened
and this is also where the sand pile
model and self-organized criticality
happened so these are massive
discoveries walk us through your time at
the National Lab and how these things
emerged yeah so this is actually related
to my interest in collective behavior
when many individuals that when they
interact together in physics at a time
so in graduate school I by some chance I
learned there are say a phenomena called
one a wife noise is a very rich
phenomena it's a little technical but
basically many things like the Twingo of
the star like the fluctuation of stock
market like the flow of river nyow nyow
they are fluctuating in time right fast
and slow
right and then stock market up and down
and if you ask what's a time scale
fluctuation seconds or hours or days
stock markets are there in seconds or
hours or days or month or even years and
then people found that the fracture is
is in all time scales they're very fast
fluctuations and they're slow
fluctuations and there are slow
fluctuations are also being posed on to
each other so this is a very fascinating
example of scale invariance so a
phenomena where you don't have typical
scale in time okay and then also you
have this phenomena you have scale
invariance in space and the energy for
example earthquake we hear about big
earthquakes will hear much less about
huge earthquakes well in fact there are
many many more small earthquakes you
don't hear about it because it's not
newsworthy if you record all these
earthquakes small medium and big and ask
how powerful they are they fit the power
law perfectly okay that many many small
earthquakes and some in median meat
medium earthquakes few big wise very
very rare huge ones again there's no
typical scale there's no earthquake say
okay most earthquakes are three Richter
scale or fibrous care no from one
Richter scale to 10 Richter scale even
larger they all exist it's just a
frequency the cases power low so that's
another example of scaling mirrors and
we also have examples of landscape and
sea line if you use a stick to measure
it then you will find out that there are
large wanderings and small meandering
and even smaller little fluctuations in
space again there's no scale so all this
phenomena exist in nature what's the
mechanism so inquiry in Cresco I was
interested in wildlife noise
the scaling variance in time during my
postdoc I had a very very free time
my supervisor per park he is very very
liberal
so essentially whatever I do interesting
that's fine
so I can think about all these things
and then eventually we collaborate it's
because we think this is wonderful
wonderful thing we and then with another
postdoc for the reason felt we realized
that all this phenomena possible it can
be explained by a simple concept we call
self-organized criticality and i
criticality it means that things on the
verge of break it's critical okay and I
breaking continuously
you can generate all these fluctuations
in space and time without a typical
scale the example can be illustrated by
Sentai that's why we use a senpai model
too to illustrate it so imagine in the
peach you build up senpai piety insane
okay originally the pie was flat and
there's no little avalanches only small
lines as a power gets steeper and
steeper you had more in the most sense
sometimes these large a large july
avalanches and then eventually they
reach a critical point where the senpai
will not get most deeper you will just
fluctuate around the critical angle of
repose right but the fluctuation can be
very interesting you can have small
avalanches large our lounges or some
avalanches size in between so that's a
scale invariance so this this game areas
the system is self organized you don't
have to carefully change anything like a
temperature or something you just drive
it by adding sand slowly you drive the
system toward some instability
and the system will stay at this verge
of instability okay if you drive it too
much you have instability that would be
our range happening they were returned
to a more stable State so it's
continuously fluctuating or stay at a
critical point so that's the name
self-organized criticality what a
fascinating discovery when we're in such
a relatable example where so many of us
are children and we put the the sand and
sand and sand and then we notice that
one more clump of sand can sometimes do
nothing just add to it or sometimes the
little clump or even just a little grain
can cause a big avalanche and then it
goes back to stability and the the
applications of this sort of
understanding are so interesting when
we're talking about what is like what
does the these this inner life of the
cell that is smart enough to basically
have some sort of an understanding of
what's happening inside the cell what's
happening in the environment outside the
cell so like almost keeping like a
ledger of what's happening inside the
cell what's happening outside of the
cell and then it gets to some sort of a
point of in a sense maybe the amount of
the amount of proteins continue
increasing in the cell and then at some
point the cell goes safe to divide and
then cell divides yeah that's a that's a
I would say that's a different kinds of
complexity it's a it's also a complex
phenomena life is the most fascinating
complex phenomena the self-organized
criticality it's a it's a compare with
life it's a simple complexity let's say
although although recently people found
that within within life they're also
phenomena like self-organized
criticality
not a brain activity the upper-end
avalanches brain aval yeah it's like
neurons they fire together as soon as
you say when I go back to the United
States and someone says Alan how was
China associative web goes crazy so many
cruel experiences that I want to now
share mm-hmm yeah so it may have
something to do with information
processing but life on other hand
offered us many many different kinds of
complexity cell is one example right a
cell looks very you know innocent but
it's very complex in fact it has to face
all kinds of difficult decisions to make
for example a single-cell organism
bacteria or yeast yeah it has to decide
when to divide when to preserve its
energy yeah and it has ways to measure
the environmental information and
somehow integrate the information to
help it to make decision so settle that
decision-making so that's very
fascinating and also I study cell cycle
the life is actually very robust imagine
that all of us a product of a fertilized
egg that's a single cell we divide
divide divide divide divide tens of
trillions and then not only this they
have all kinds of different several
hundred different cell types mmm
how did they know the meteor than always
yeah how do they know and how do they
how do they not make mistake yeah when
divides the copy DNA not pursue the
aliens will be killing raised fears
don't copy the DNA yeah how do they make
sure that it's a the DNA is no mistake
it's time to divide and you grab the
chromosome pair sister chromatids to
divide equally into two cells and all
this we call robustness para
robustness so later I was interested in
complexity in biology the first problem
I worked on was protein folding was on
proteins protein also very fascinating
amino acid sequence fold into
three-dimensional structure very
precisely a unique sequence following
unique structure yes no mistake
occasional mistake occasional mistake
yeah and even the sequence has some
mutations in many cases it was also fold
into the same structure so this caused
robustness ok instruct yourself the very
robust is the lowest free energy state
meaning that any other fold way of
folding it the energy is higher so more
dynamically so I I studied I asked why
proteins are so robust from a
statistical physics point of view yes
then you know I was fascinated
we found something also very interesting
with co.design ability this is because
the protein structures are highly
desirable the way they wound around the
filter to each other not all the
structures are can be made protein
structures the only sodium structures
they are so stable so that many
sequences can fold them and make them
the lowest energy state okay so to say
it is a design ability concept then
later on we move to study our cell the
network cell cycle Network for example
you can ask a similar question why
they're so robust
why they don't write on them make
mistakes you know in the cell is very
crowded there are many proteins they
pump into each other they don't have
eyes to just diffuse and then if we are
friends we just stay a little bit longer
and then we'll be hit by other proteins
or water or the swimmer motion will be
the pathway
so it's all this kind of very noisy and
wyman crowd and why I'm in this cell on
the other hand they can perform all
these very precise functions like cell
division yes right and then you can ask
why and there we studied from a
mathematics point of view nonlinear
dynamics you can write down differential
equations or boolean logic Network like
how one protein is talking to other
proteins and then you simulates the
network you found that the system is
very robust it is for example there's a
huge attractor no matter where you start
the will go to this very stable cellular
state and then the cell cycle path is
also very robust even you make some
mistakes that many noises next thermal
noise or the fluctuations of protein
numbers but the dynamics is the
relationship between these proteins well
force you converge into this
superhighway which will lead you for the
cell division process yeah interesting
you can map out protein dynamics and how
they lead onto the superhighway towards
that's naughty that's right you can
understand the form you can understand
it from a mathematical point from a
mathematical point of view the
quantitative biology side of things
that's right
so this understanding of the source code
of biology mathematically mapped most
people say this is chaos theory how can
you possibly map it what can it unlock
for us as we do map it what does it end
up doing for us so many incredible
applications which we'll talk about
you've started to unpack I want us to
visit this on the way you mentioned this
it's just such an important
understanding of our world scale
invariance 1 over F noise power loss
mm-hmm so when I look at something like
earthquake magnitudes they gave us this
example and they're all over nature all
over nature right though in the rain
forest very similarly 20% of the trees
sequester 80% of the carbon and then
they do cool things like sequester it
and distributed amongst its roof
networks to other trees that don't get
as much carbon we're humans we can maybe
learn a couple things from that style of
distribution and access yeah yeah
there's analogies there that I've been
writing and speaking about a little bit
but ok there's that one there's so many
of these examples ok then all of a
sudden we see ourselves as well in the
way that we also have acquired resources
20% of the people have 80% of the wealth
that maybe also be 20% of the people
have 80 percent of the overall spiritual
enlightenment and let's say there's so
many ways to view at 20 percent people
own 80% of all and all the same stuff so
humans aren't actually separate from
nature in the power law distribution but
ok let's look at what who humans are
oddly nature we aren't yes we are not
separate yeah we are versed right in it
and also by the way they I don't think
all the power loss they have a unique
mechanism there can be different
mechanisms or different power laws
different power laws for for power laws
of different systems for example so
maybe why 20% of people occupying 80% of
resources it's not self-organized
criticality
something else what would you
hypothesize it I don't know maybe it's a
some some economic systems it's a way
how the economy is running and the rules
and regulations that are maybe reshaped
in favor of those that have accumulated
more it's its interest in the in a way I
think I believe the society has been
trying to optimize the efficiency right
economic efficiency yes maybe there's
some I already made a model I don't know
when he asked if I make a model of
economics of productivity yes if I'm
optimize efficiency is that outcome is
the most efficient the Catholic
economics is like this or not I don't
know that's interesting question I had a
message that I started communicating to
leaders in my network I started asking
them ok is there a center for economic
simulation yet cannot yeah there are
yeah
I'm curious how robustly they've tagged
all of the variables that happen in an
economy and then can do things like
deploy in a code to the economic
simulation literally a digital twin of
the Chinese economy
mmm-hmm let's take the US economy for
example and then you deploy an update
let's say the proposed basic income ok
$1,000 a month the people deploy it and
then see what happens in the simulation
same thing with well what if we put a
half a percent tax on all Wall Street
transactions same thing so you deploy it
see what happens in the simulation I'm
very interested in that I'm also
interested you can explain this if I get
this wrong when you look at let's take a
1 over F noise and scale invariance
again so when you take a a wave length
mm-hmm and you
you zoom in on the wavelength huh you
see the same thing the same repeating
form and as when you zoom out zoom out
zoom out this is right and you see this
you see the same form although the you
may see different amplitude okay but you
do the say see very similar for the
status power distribution of different
wavelengths coming back to the and we
see this in fractals do you see this in
fact I love the fraction right yeah yeah
I can't help but coming back to the
economics problem yes yeah you know you
may argue that or one may argue that
optimize productivity may not be our
purpose maybe we won't optimize
happiness of everyone
yes yeah how to balance it yeah this is
a whole open question yes yeah but your
question is very interesting what
principles made this 8020 distribution
yes yeah
could have literally been in the initial
source code of when the Big Bang
happened that nature nature evolves this
way I don't believe it okay to tell us
why yeah I I think yeah I think a big
pair certainly created the universe and
we are part of it after we have planets
we have the solar system and then life
evolved and there are many accidents
along the way of evolution
I don't seem to dare say you know fixed
destiny destiny starting from the Big
Bang it's just too many fluctuations and
noise and uncertainties even from
classical mechanics that along the
quantum mechanics has intrinsic and
swelling this yeah yeah so we are
actually many a product of many
accidents but there are some which could
also be programmed in my program I think
if you mean they say they say some
general principles mm-hmm that I believe
they exist just like the amino acids
accidentally miss folding when they fold
into the protein yeah why 20 amino acids
that's accident in a sliding with the
planet accident yeah enabling humans to
evolve
yeah but why protein structures this way
if we have 26 seminars as a team amino
acids I think the protein structures are
reasonably robust if life evolved in
mass and compared with us I think that
many details will be different yeah but
many principles will be the same for
example the distance from the star is a
big one of course there's yeah for
example the idea that you found on the
fly you have to obey hydrodynamics now
you have to have to have bins then you
ate of want to swim you have to have
this shape and we have to ice because we
can see the distance to many I said to
come top to complicate it then they are
certain principles
the universal principles and in fact I'm
reinjure stood in at this point to look
inside the complexity of about biologic
complexity and trying to find principles
universal principles let's start talking
about those and and this actually came
after I mean we there's just so many
other incredible things that you dude
along the way spend time at the
Institute for Theoretical Physics in
Santa Barbara who worked at Nippon
electronics corporation which actually
de pond is how you were teaching me
that's how Japanese reference Japan as
pound and Nepal East Japan and then see
you wasn't like the US or the UK were
just like let's call it Japan and the
whole world to start calling you Japan
versus instant just Japan calls Japan
Nippon but the rest of the world calls
it and this is crazy so it's like they
used to call speaking right in fact we
call ourselves Beijing very similar why
you call picking which was the old yeah
oh this is old but by oh the meaning
that some old British he or she decided
we called peaking right I could do some
rule I don't know okay and you were with
NEC for 14 years so 30 and a half 30 sec
yeah and also during that time you
pursued your interest in biology and
this totally makes sense with biology
and physics being smashed together
elected as a fellow at the American
Physical Society and then you were going
back to China every year during the
summer and this was for conferences
giving seminars teaching and that's when
you started the Center for quantitative
biology then you were a professor of
biophysics at UCSF for six years and
then you came back to pecking university
to chair the professor of physics and
systems biology and being the principal
investigator at the tongue lab now so
now
let's talk about how you got you plus
the 20-30 undergraduate graduate
students are studying quantity of
biological systems and you're finding
these biological principles how first
out of everything in biology and physics
do you guys decide where to try and
identify biological principles in corn
to take a clean you have you pick what
to study that's a question every
undergraduate student and to some extent
I regret your students we're asked how
do you pick problems right I don't think
there's an answer for that and there's
no standard answer let's say it's it's a
is part of science right it's what what
problems are interesting
what do you see after problem when you
solve it is that meaningful with that
have an impact
scientifically not technologically I'd
say I think it's all personal choice in
a way so that's why science is
fascinating there's no common recipe to
do science but every scientist for
various reasons historical training
interest they have their own way to pick
up problems and eventually they get they
learned this also you may get lost and
some of my students they got lost
in the first few years how to look for
problems but eventually we learn and it
gets better and better
it's like Fermi and Rico firmly set for
physicist we have the sixth sense okay
we have a smell what is good science in
a way to education for students is
really this is the most important thing
you have to learn taste of science
to pick good problems okay so that's a
sort of generator in practice I let my
students to pick their own problems yeah
I just try to correct create the
environment for them of our environment
of bring interesting problems the open
discussion and then they try to find
their own problems I think it worked
yeah so okay so so to most to be more
specific we don't pick problems because
we are interested in a specific system
or a particular protein or particular
disease or a particular pathway so we
don't pick a problem and say ok we're
going to conquer cancer then we try to
see what is the problem again study to
Congress cancer and that's not our way
of picking problems you know in our lab
so we pick a problem we think it's
interesting scientifically because by
investigating it by solving it you will
gain a broader general hopefully
universal knowledge
[Music]
it's a it's more like curiosity-driven
so to give you example so why people
study magnetism and electricity hundreds
or even thousands years ago I don't
think they realize we can have lights
we studied actually then we can have
lights
it's very purposeful I don't think they
realize that electricity and the
magnetism two parts of the same coin to
site-to-site of same coin and Maxwell
unified it and then we have
electromagnetic wave then we have
wireless communication we have all these
huge applications nobody knows they're
just out of curiosity okay what is
electricity
what is magnetism Oh electricity gets
generated magnetism magnesium can induce
lectricity what are the rules what are
the laws what are the equations can
unify them so that's how the most
fundamental science advanced this is
electro magnetism
quantum mechanics very similar not very
purposeful to solve in a particular
problem but out of curiosity I want to
understand okay and then the the way we
pick up a lot your problems we want to
understand in a way of physicists point
of view understand I won't use
quantitative ways to understand we won't
have equations no boundaries extract
principles so that's a general way of
picking problems so my lab is if you
look at my lab they study all kinds of
different things unrelated but the rate
is there's a general theme behind
we're gonna dive deeper into this style
of interdisciplinary or
multidisciplinary thinking which is very
embedded in your life with the study of
physics and then biology and how those
merged and let's go into okay as you are
describing this it comes up to me that a
lab in a sense could say hmm let's apply
a power-law style of understanding where
we could potentially invest our
resources so can we find the 20% of
quantitative biology that's gonna give
us 80% of the knowledge of how
quantitative biology actually works okay
so if you take it from that angle maybe
you have like a think tank habit
constantly happening at your lab where
they're constantly thinking what are the
key scientific drivers of quantitative
biology and then how do we conduct
experiments to understand those keys
that can then go off into the world and
then inspire other scientists and labs
to keep driving the understanding
forward so came up and then but I also
realized that the way that you talk
about it inevitably leads to when you
let the students pick and explore it
inevitably also leads to that where you
have a couple of the kids that are doing
these core competencies of quantitative
biology and then other ones that are
maybe doing like more like something to
deal with like an orphan style problem
let's say where it's only impacting a
smaller percentage of people but those
people are obviously neat science driven
towards solving that style of a problem
like an orphan disease or whatnot
okay now let's break this down so you
gave us a couple of these source codes
that you're aiming to drive our
understanding towards solving complex
diseases designing new therapeutic
strategies but you gotta know how the
cell makes decisions and you call this
cell cycle
regulation mm-hmm what is how is the
cell making decisions
does it keep like we were talking but
does it keep a ledger of what's
happening within the cell and excellent
excellent that's happening outside of
the cell do I have a ledger in fact one
of the work which was just accepted was
exactly what you said it's a ledger the
cell or the memory about the past
environmental condition and use that
memory to decide to make decisions for
the current okay so the you know for for
example for the single-cell organism
budding yeast the organism or used to
make beer bread by the East our friend
it's a mod organism so we use that to
study cellular decision cell cycle
regulation so we found that the cell
integrate the past condition to make
help to help make the current decision
how did do that okay first of all
there's a very important checkpoint
called start for the east this
checkpoint is to for the cell to decide
should I go through the process of
division or not this is very important
why because I have to make the decision
to make sure I have enough resources to
replicate my genome to divide okay on
the other hand you can't wait too long
because what if your competitor the mix
mother decision that divided faster than
you then you're out competed so this is
a optimal
decision how you use environmental
information how you know that now it's a
right time to go through the division
process wait but not too long this is
several decision
kind of like we wait but not too long
yeah okay marriage for exactly you can't
afford the wait forever yeah yeah I'd
like marriage that you would be you
can't find nobody you can't wait till
you're 60 all right same for the cell
and so through the billions of years of
evolution they became very smart to make
the decision so there's a crucial
checkpoint very critical checkpoint and
what them what makes them to pass this
checkpoint to make the commitment of
division is to take all this
environmental information like what's
the new trend condition around me how
big I am
you know how much storage I have for the
food four four four four resources and
all this and people know this and they
studied although it's not completely
clear but people know that they they use
and integrate the current information so
what we recently discovered that they
even use the past information so cell
current ledger but also cell memory
exactly so they remember the past cycle
from the last division to up to now to
current how long I experienced the
longer the journey I experienced which
means the condition is worse because you
grow slower everything slower you take
you longer to reach the current status
the shoulder the journey means that the
other conditions are good so you grow
fast your copy DNA faster divided faster
you you your ideas current status so
this longer or shorter is the best sort
of characteristic of past condition
so that remember this length of path
journey by a concentration of a protein
the longer the journey the higher
concentration of this protein the
shoulders that you earned the lower
concentration of this protein and this
protein happened to be the gatekeeper of
this checkpoint
so the path journeys long which means
the past condition has been tough just
protein Hawkinson would be high to the
bar to pass this checkpoint is high so
the cell has to grow longer or to get
more signals of the current conditions
are really good to pass it what an
incredible way to understand smart
memory a harder journey for the cell to
be more careful to be more careful which
means okay our protein threshold is this
higher exactly before we decide to take
the next right and if it was easy
protein door shows lower correct and
then okay you don't have to be so
careful you can just pass but you have
to integrate current information by the
PI slower you can use microscopy to see
how many proteins are in the cell
correct we can yeah we can quantify it
yes in your quantification methods right
now use which tools we label the protein
with Flores for essence about protein
refused the protein we saw with GFP
green fluorescence protein and then you
can see it under the microscope the
brighter which means more protein higher
concentration so we can quantify and how
do you add the GFP oh that's genetics
that's easy
thanks for the revolution for molecular
biology you can fuse the gene of GFP to
the gene of this protein in the genome
you can insert yeah I and you're
inserting the GFP gene into
the first cell of yeast or which just
oneself east and the mother told all the
others get yeah okay all the generations
who I have this gene okay yes into the
first cell yeast and then do you then
take as it proliferate whether it's slow
proliferation or fast proliferation
that's why you take in sequence those
and then you see the sequences that we
just we just ended microscope you can
see how fluorescence yet for essence
okay and then we can grow the yeast and
the different conditions good condition
bad condition stressed condition we add
salt so that you know you can change all
kinds of conditions for the past
experience and you see the accumulation
of this protein okay okay okay so that
is is that our first understanding of
cell memory like in no I would say the
first understanding but this is the
first understanding how it cell use
memory to regulate this checkpoint the
cell cycle
okay let's start check this is or you
call the start yeah checkpoint sta RT
that's right okay not recall it D
hardware called it it is covered this
checkpoint and got a Nobel Prize
beautiful it's so beautiful okay so now
this is one of the the cell memory plus
cell ledger coming together into this
cell cellular dynamics and okay
so what are the other this ones are
obviously very important this protein
threshold and shall I is am I ready to
divide okay okay this mid this one is
very obviously very important will have
what other ones have we and uncovered
what other cellular dynamics like this
another example is that stem cell
reprogramming you know we all over
ourselves from one fertilized egg a big
stem cell right when they divide and
divide and divide the committee to
different cell fate
so each cell type is actually fate and
that's also a fate decision when you
become a skin cell when you come in your
own cell and all the cells have one
genome but different fates okay and now
it's very scientifically and
technologically very important to
reverse the process to take a muscle
cells skin cell to transfer it back to a
stem cell so from one cell fate to
another cell fate where are there many
applications you use the stem cell can
grow heart maybe a pancreas for example
can have many medical applications but
we're interested in the science of it
how can sell change fates yes yeah on
how how do we this is so crazy
yeah and the idea many years ago
[Music]
scientists including the Japanese
scientist Yamanaka they discovered you
maybe you remember the name yamandakka
yamandakka yamandakka yeah they
discovered that for a normal cell a
differential cell when you add certain
genes which are usually expressed in
stem cell you can transfer this normal
cell into a stem cell so by gene
transfer transformation you get a change
you express your head expressed genes
which are normally expressed in a stem
cell okay for that he caught today he
won the Nobel Prize it's a very big
discovery but what's the Mac what's the
principle behind it can we use
mathematics to model it if we can model
it then making maybe we can understand
more we can get we can gain deeper
insights okay and then we are very lucky
we got interested in this problem simply
we have a wonderful colleague on cretan
a professor in pic university so he
studied stem cell and they found
something very interesting they found
that you don't have to use Yamanaka
recipe of the stem cell genes to induce
themselves in fact you can replace some
stem cell genes with some other
differentiated cell genes
still induce stem cells so this is a
very counterintuitive say in order to
for a for example for a for for a muscle
cell to become a stem cell of course you
want you intuitively you want to let the
muscle cell express even artificially
the stem cell genes so then you have a
hope right if i want to look like you
they i want i better to to take take a
picture and make my eyes look like you
my nose look like you and then maybe i
can really be look like you this is not
a good idea but they found that they can
use some other genes so that sounds like
a really messed up the system and then
the Sepik came stem cell so we study
collaboration with them we start to
write down equations mathematical
equations to describe the interactions
of the genes the genes interact the stem
cell genes that promote each other and
then they have their favorite downstream
genes to promote but the downstream
genes for different fates they hate each
other and they also they don't like stem
cell genes it's a it's a it's a
relationship so different genes
therefore comprehension in the fight we
can use quantitative biology and yes
mathematical corrects to take a stem
cell and
changing into whatever we want not
whatever we want we can use mathematics
to understand how and why a stem cell
can become another cell faith and
another cell faith can become a stem
stem cell so we could map out the the
cell lineage of something as complex as
a human being from single cell becoming
just stating inside of mom all the way
to baby that's being born and then that
evolving into not the whole complexity
not yet not yet
yeah but for the force for certain
special cases okay
so certain differential is cell not all
the differentiate cell so maybe they are
some we don't let might understand
for those we understood the genetic
interactions like what's the master gene
for this differential cell why they
muscle cell how I design your own cell
no because in the muscle cell the genes
are muscle one so they then they repress
all the other neuron like genes right
yet won he won you won the fight Tristan
another one that they win they win right
and actually she self fate it's like a
bunch of genes they win their muscle and
then your own heart and stem cell is
like nobody yet dominating and all only
the stem surgeons are playing we are
dominating okay and then there are kinds
of signals there are all kinds of ways
for stem cell to be induced the words
muscle or neuro and but all this can be
described in certain cases when we know
enough about the relationship of these
genes by mathematical equations
at some point we go from the single cell
to 2 to 4 to 8 to 16 etc and at some
point there becomes the the the brain
cells start to the neurons start to win
the heart cells and start to win the not
results the best result that's right you
have all kinds of signals during the
rough development in space and time to a
certain point and this bunch of cells
differentiate into specific cells and
another point another space these cells
would develop into another fate correct
yes and that's called you guys call it
cell fate or self-determination cell
fate yeah yeah different cell types
different fate as yeah we called cell
fate because it's really a fate for cell
it is to become a neurons and you know
forever
yes yeah yeah is only artificially you
can make the change its fate but usually
it doesn't change the fate how is it
that not similar to if Alan is born in
Sioux Falls South Dakota in 1992 to the
specific parent of the specific
environmental status and socioeconomic
status that Alan will just over and over
and over again have the same fate 80
years later besides maybe that slight
mutation every millions of iterations
but for all the cells you know in the
failure more or less fixed right well
some but Alan as a whole
Ln as a whole could get hit by a bus
that's a different fate okay that's
that's many many other environmental
inferences yes
deterministic or accidental stochastic
right hmm so that's that's that's
different fate
for the self ad section of more
deterministic more determine the very
precise and Alan is a little bit more
open to free will let's say potentially
versus when the cell the sperm meets the
egg this is a pretty deterministic that
you're going to get a baby in nine
months that's pretty healthy that's
right and also this is this fertilized
egg will develop into a human being
yes yes no the hardwired yes you know
and that's that's pretty much
deterministic but also there are many
things that accidental especially later
on the connection the strength of the
connection of our neurons it's by
learning by experience yes and then if
you were can be very different given if
you were born in the exact same location
with the exact same parents at the exact
same environmental stimuli at the exact
same time and in a bubble well that you
would probably become who you are today
again and again everything is exact yeah
I will become I would say of course we
don't understand this at the point at
this point okay it's a whole scientific
community I don't think we completely
understand this I will become I don't
know maybe seventy percent the same I
would say seventy eighty there's still
about twenty thirty percent uncertainty
variance you know all those all those
are purely due to sell sell variability
even everything is the same the two
cells can be different simply because
all this process of a gene making a
protein it's stochastic so to exact the
same cell one cell can make this
probably more and that will be less so
this stochasticity and this can make a
difference big difference a big
difference line darkness ok so from the
point of of being one cell to being a
baby nine months later less
variability then once you come out of
the womb into the world over 80 years
more downstream variability potential
you gave it about 20 to 30 percent
eventually yeah but the you know you in
the womb when they develop that's this
kind of cell severability also about the
same percentage you would say less
identical twins for example yeah
identical twins when they just born
that's an engine question how similar
they are mm-hmm yes how similar their
brains of the connectivity yeah I would
imagine that's just some variability but
not by a lot but later on this a large
enlarging inference this variability but
but not by a lot kind of reminds me of
the hypothetical that there's another
doctor chou-heung orbiting another star
in another parallel universe where he's
slightly different than this one and
then there's another billion of those
parallel universes running different
doctor shot songs all at the same time
and who knows what happens during dreams
if maybe during those eight hours that
you go and visit those parallel doctor
child tongues yes yes okay so this is
all about I love this cellular decision
making and understanding how simplicity
evolves to complexity and the more that
we build tools that understand the
source codes of the simplicity the
better we can understand over time in
space how it evolves into complexity
what other tools do you in your lab want
to build to understand the source code
of the simplicity well no specificity
tools who we really want to build we
mostly we use existing tools like
microscope at GFP
differential equations mmm and recently
artificial intelligence yeah I teachers
about this so we use the existing tools
and then we developed a tool usually f2
to modify it into the specific problems
you are studying and then the of course
we always keep our mind open to to
discover something brand-new so
personally I believe although I may not
be I'm sure I will not be the one to
discover it but I believe there will be
new math for example you know simply by
studying the life phenomenon yeah yeah
so like cellular decision-making will
make it would be new math that we
uncover example all how we think how the
brain how the brain function and how do
we describe life what's the mathematical
language what's the logic yes I don't
know but I feel that our current math is
not quite there to describe the essence
of life normally not so there will be
new math coming and I believe there'll
be new physics okay and all these
physics we can explain quite well many
small things elementary things and also
things are in equilibrium but life is
say as we said they say very complex
complicated emergent phenomena it's open
system we take energy we learn we take
information so what's the new physics so
I believe we will have new math new
physics are you a new computer science
our computer is completely different
framework architecture than our brain
how we too can computation is very
different from computer
if we know more than Wow
no no more and more about our brain we
can make better computers we can be
smarter
what machine can be smarter so now the
artificial intelligence the deeper
neural network very hot right beat the
co-champion watch champion you just
learned a little bit of brain structure
right that can be very powerful so it's
going to be very exciting to have this
brain science and computer science
couple together there'll be many new
tools and new science
yeah at this point we will use deep
neural network transit and biological
system try to extract the genetic
interaction as I just described all the
genes some are friends some enemies the
fight the help each other so it's very
dynamic when cell make decisions very
dynamic when they when the replica is
very dynamic
when when the two metabolism is very
dynamic okay
when the to sell phase transitions
transformation very dynamic so we if we
know more and more about these genetic
interactions we know more and more about
the cell about the cellular interactions
about the organism but how do we know
how you know how can we speed up this
traditionally we do genetics
biochemistry molecular biology trying to
figure out you know so-called low
throughput ik by low throughput
experiments so that's very powerful it's
very very efficient but now there are
more and more tools to preserve the
cellular behavior to see the Chi
expression as I said we can fuse a GFP
to see the protein concentration go up
and down which time well we can see many
protein concentration Co happened
and down in the cell so we have all this
information can we use this information
to guess to infer the genetic
interaction other friends are the
enemies so we use neural network
artificial intelligence to do this it's
been fun
yeah ok so the lab has been identifying
and you have been identifying now over
decades the best tools for you to use
with your own added ideas and added
experimental processes to be able to
understand quantitative biology better
and better and so then when you add
something like artificial intelligence
and computational capacities that are
evolving so rapidly to something like
the chaos theory of biology it enables
us to faster and faster get the
quantitative biological source codes
that we want to know you gave this
example of like what I feel like is a
theory of everything that will
eventually emerge you said probably not
in your time maybe in mine who knows but
that can merge quantum mechanics general
relativity those two and then how that
initial source code and it's up creating
complex biological phenomenon that
evolve civilizations that then begin to
poke at the source code that then
potentially just make another cycle and
of life well okay so the theory of
everything it's not the theory of
everything in the usual sense by the
physicists and there they want to unify
general relativity gravity and every
these the basic forces of nature right I
don't I don't believe general relativity
or special relativity is relevant to
life in nominal
quantum mechanics maybe yes yeah so I I
meant theory for life it's a new theory
it may be new mathematics okay
in fact at every level of nature at
every scale there can be a new theory
with elementary particles with quarks
right and then we have nucleus we have
nuclei we have molecule we have a matter
with you know solid liquid gas and then
we have life with galaxies we have
universe with life and and and all these
levels they all they can all emerge very
special theory for example in physics
the thermodynamics in statistical
physics
it's emerged from many interaction of
molecules and atoms it's a new law the
phenomena you cannot observe in a single
particle also it doesn't help if you
understand a single particle you can
understand the general behavior of water
you understand oxygen you understand
hydrogen giving you understand single
water molecule you still don't
understand or input many many water
molecules together how they behave will
be the gas or ice or liquid so that's a
new level of theory and the science is
trying to link all these levels yes yeah
okay but it doesn't mean that if you
know the lowest level you can derive you
can understand all the level it doesn't
work that way
sometimes you understand higher level
first and then you try to link to the
lower level okay sometime you understand
lower level and the push to the higher
level yes so it's going yeah in between
back in the force mapping the source has
both directions that's right yeah that's
right and biology and the higher level
maybe it's psychology right and then
maybe Society
all those molecules interacting I have
my personality
yeah of psychology yeah how today how
psychology emerge from biology is the
most complex thing in the universe of
human civilization right I believe not
what could what could be more complex
than that then I think brain can be more
complex in that but is the brain within
all eight billion of us together isn't
that civilization include the eight
billion brains see your eyes we have
many historians and many great history
books they can describe the human
civilization reasonably well and they
can given reason why they come from this
step to that step the Stone Age the
Bronze Age Industrial Revolution there's
another single theory yet to write the
history book our brain why we have
consciousness yeah how memory works yes
why we can sit here and to talk talk to
each other yes yes okay I don't know
it's just my feeling do with the rival
to was as complex as human civilization
is hew the human brain mm-hmm see I
think the human civilization for us it
seems to be easy to understand because
we don't have to go from the brain level
to understand it right we just go from
individual behavior like okay human we
need have to eat we have to have to live
and then they interact there's something
for them to optimize they win the power
they fight so you can you can start from
some higher level basic rules and some
shion's
and then to describes the emergence of
human civilization right so that's why I
said sometimes you don't have to go down
you don't have to understand brain to
assume some basic
a Grigri ingredients so what's the basic
ingredient of human society right the
food the living resources air water air
water and shelter yeah and the people
fight for this we will collaborate for
this and yeah and they organize to put
them tell you themselves yeah yeah yeah
this is kind of far um wow wow yeah so
understanding source codes from
civilization and human brain levels and
the behavioral dynamics of the
civilization like psychology narrow and
of course including and neuroscience in
the way that that emergent phenomenon
works while simultaneously we go and
understand the initial moments of the
Big Bang and we understand quantum
mechanics and general relativity and and
and up we go to atom to atoms and
molecules and cells and and and then
yeah and then we meet and that together
can unlock not only what gives us the
better education the better healthcare
the better technology the better society
more happy people more creative people
better world harmony that as long as our
ethics and our morals and our wisdom
Rises at the same time is very important
but it also enables us to do things like
take that source code and then run our
own evolutions our own simulations and
run quadrillions of them and just
observe what happens just like in this
case you're running simulations of yeast
and you're we're running and watching
how the cell has a fate of becoming a
heart or becoming a brain and
the depth of of of under seeing the
source code of quantum of quantitative
biology here is extremely applicable at
all over the levels of understanding the
source code yeah yeah I think that's why
I said in the beginning I think science
and technology are really the driving
force for the society and for the human
civilization and really we have a very
very very open field for us to explore
and all kinds of opportunities and of
course all this ethics they have to come
up yeah ha ha can clone a human being
you know when the AI is also developed
how do you combine human and AI to what
extent you can combine them there are
all kinds of issues but I think I'm
optimistic I think a science advanced
technology device well face all these
issues but we are sort of advanced
that's very exciting to us we have
bright future yes
likewise very optimistic I want to make
sure that we talk about the importance
of interdisciplinary and
multidisciplinary studies it's now
become more and more clear that through
our conversation obviously you took a
very physics and biology and non
mathematical and computational now
perspectives that are helping you with
this but also just me as as someone
that's interviewing people at all on all
different fields are giving me a very
strong worldview that is making very
interesting connections across
disciplines you guys even at your lab in
your Center for quantitative biology you
have to practice website design and
marketing and selling and grant writing
so you can get the newer
then you've be good storytellers to
inspire other people to care about
quantitative biology and to be
collaborators with you so if you can be
a good artist and designer and
storyteller while you're a good
scientist and stuff you really have a
creative edge and I want you to speak to
why you care so much about
interdisciplinary multidisciplinary
Studies and how your students as well
practice that yeah this is really a a
mode of scientific research and the
different modes you can stay in the
within a discipline and you can go
across disciplines
I wouldn't say which is right which is
wrong which is better which is worse I
think we need all of them the trends in
the last century or so is that the
discipline has become more and more
specific in the barrier between
disciplines has become higher and higher
and then in the last decade or two maybe
even longer
scientists realized that we have to a
cross we have to break this barriers and
in fact if you see many new discoveries
new breakthroughs they're really at the
boundary of two or more disciplines and
if you also if you ask some societal
questions like air pollution like even
cancer okay or how long can we live all
these are really not a single discipline
problems it's a problem of many
disciplines so you need perspective of
from different disciplines you need
people from different disciplines to
work together from educational point of
view I think at least some fraction of
students they have to be educated
broad-minded
so that the discipline is not a war your
friend of them so that they will not see
a problem our this is a math problem I
can only solve the mathematical part of
it oh this is a physics problem oh this
is not physics problem so I don't know
how to solve it you just see this a
scientific problem right and then you
just use whatever knowledge whatever
tools you can utilize right so that and
there that has to be nurtured educated
from the very beginning so that's why we
have this all the interdisciplinary
education program and the graduate and
graduate and the science we do the
quantitative biology this biology the
subject is biology quantitative meaning
that we use other more quantitative
disciplines to study it right can be
mathematics can be physics and chemistry
or can be the science so that we can
discover things you if you only studied
from a large purse pecked --iv you
cannot discover we can discover new
things yeah yeah we really adore and
just prioritize this style of thinking
we need them all like you listed we need
people that are just going really hard
and just math as well of course but to
and we kind of live we both really live
in this world we both do you have Galco
in china you have a CT SAT all GPA
whatever etc inside the united states
and there's all different types of these
tests and they do a pretty good job at
measuring IQ and measuring math and
reading skills and stuff like that okay
what about emotional intelligence what
about the emotional quotient what about
people skills empathy growth mindset
respect
taking emotional regulation meditation
spirituality what about stuff like that
and how can that even a little bit of it
at a young age how can that drastically
compound and make someone an even better
scientist down the line and same thing
with maybe a little bit of music or a
little bit of art how can that make
someone a drastically better scientist
down the line yeah I think all those are
very important I I believe general
education liberal liberal arts education
so I think a students are it's very
important that students who expose to
all kinds of things now later on they
get specific they can be specialized but
at least in the in college at college
level a high school level or younger
there should be generalists to learn to
learn many things so you integrate many
things and find their only interest to
their passion yeah I absolutely agree I
mean we need all those who said yeah
including music and arts yeah yeah yeah
I have a music I have musician friends I
have artistic artists friends I I really
like to be with them yeah inspiring
yes a worship suits I write I am a
generalist Oh [ __ ] songs i yeah i am
a polymath I am a generalist who shits
on sites were systems I yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay so I learned that one hmm
while I was here mm-hmm because I
thought it was so important and the
other one will should Gigi Gigi but I'm
a journalist mmm yeah mmm oh you got it
yeah
journalist I was teaching that one
journalist but yeah we have whoosh it's
on site I love these systems hey or
should sometime a polymath I'm a
generalist that's how I that's how I
learned that there's probably multiple
ways Chinese is so interesting and
difficult but again this idea that if
you expose children at young ages to all
different types of tools and
methodologies of learning and then let
them do things like you're like okay
here's the 17th United Nations
sustainable development goals pick and
try and tackle these problems
project-based learning tackling these
problems I don't necessarily know SAT a
CT cow cow that type of stuff probably
excellent in many ways at the same time
project-based learning around solving
the sustainable development goals
helping children explore being
generalists and stuff like that
I'd also welcome that a little bit more
in our world what do you think the
meaning of life that's interesting I
everybody thought about it a certain
stage of his or her life I believe yeah
now I don't think it's so much actually
I feel it I feel fascinating that
there's so much for us to understand to
contemplate to explore nature society
brain and also all these possibilities
of science and technology all these
consequences I imagine about imagine
about that I imaginable it's wide open
I'm just excited what's the role of love
in our world I think it's important
without love we are to try I think they
would become a machine we can be very
good but they will lose the sense of
community
a sense of us we need to laugh the big
laugh to to share the globe to share the
earth to be harmonious with each other
and to be happy with each other so
that's I think love is simple
ingredients love that and what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world
nature nature created everything and we
are trying to understand nature yeah Wow
such a mind-blowing episode thank you
chopping you show so much for thinking
on our show it's a pleasure it's been an
honor thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking have more conversations with
your friends families co-workers people
online about quantitative biology about
understanding the source code of our
reality about cellular dynamics about
everything that Chao was teaching us on
the show have more conversations about
that push the edge of what's known in
our world check out the links in the bio
below to the Tong lab also check out the
center for quantitative biology as well
here at Peking University go and come
and visit pegging University come and
visit the Center for quantitative
biology beautiful campus gorgeous campus
I can't picking University and Chinua
university are right next to each other
the funnel for brilliant people in the
world is so strong here it reminds me of
the MIT Harvard right next to each other
in Cambridge is very similar I love that
and also check out the links to
simulation and are in the bio below
support us help support us you can find
us a PayPal patreon cryptocurrency you
can design cool merch and get paid
support the artists the entrepreneurs
organizations around the world that you
believe in and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in we
love you
very much and we'll see you soon peace
[Music]
you
[Music]